holy moly it's your fanciest meal around
the machine i feel like soup gets a bad
rap struggling
oh
it looked exactly the way that i ate it
in mexico city
an indonesian soup it is one of the best
foods i've ever eaten in my life oh hi
i'm he and i'm the world's accused mom
and it's that time again i asked my
instagram followers to send me their
favorite recipes from all over the world
and i'm gonna make a different dish
every day of the week it's gonna be
delicious
fair warning my house is very noisy all
of my kids are home and it's very
yeah
and it's very
classy this week of eating foods from
around the world has clearly become a
favorite not only in my house but for
you and i get so many requests to make
another one and so many submissions of
different recipes
this is my life this is my home i do
this week of trying foods from around
the world because i want my kids to grow
up with a varied palette if i have the
recipe and i'm able to share it with you
it will be linked in the description and
here's your warning do not watch this on
an empty stomach go get a snack because
you will be hungry hi hannah my name is
danny and i'm from mexico in mexico we
have different types of possoli but my
personal favorite and one of the most
traditional ones is
i really hope you like it pisoli is a
mexican soup it's typically cooked with
pork or chicken and large corn that i
call hominy but it has a few different
names and it has an amazing broth that
can either be red
green or clear i started the broth with
chicken and water and some seasonings
got my chilies i've attempted to make
pasoli before in the past and it just
never quite tasted right i was missing
these two chilis we're gonna blend this
all up that looks good
oh
no i'm not making a smoothie this is
sauce everything smells so good in my
house it looked exactly the way that i
ate it in mexico city
[Music]
jackson really enjoyed the broth it was
not too spicy for him
i sent a photo to my followers she said
it looked accurate it meant so much to
me because this was the first time i've
tried making a food that i've actually
eaten in that country oh my goodness hi
hannah i'm lou from the netherlands i
would love for you to make my recipe for
boho
something my family eats at least once a
week i hope you enjoy
hello what are we making today henry
you want to push the button on the
coffee maker
it was a dish that i was very excited to
try because my mom and i took a cruise
to the netherlands and we went on
several food tours but we didn't try
boring coal it's a starchy potato and
kale mash with sausage got some boiling
salty water so i'm going to add my
potatoes and my kale yeah i already
managed to make a mistake and i didn't
cut the potatoes so i pulled them back
out and i've sliced them the sausage
used in this is just a smoked sausage
and it's really easy because it's
already cooked i'm not making my own
sausage
i live with enough sausage oh my god
don't include that you can just boil it
in the package but i'm heating it on the
skillet it's a great way to get kids to
eat kale nice trick you know it had some
interesting seasonings that i had never
tried in a potato mash before i have
this
what why do you have an ipad this little
lurker
the boys loved it it was a really hearty
delicious dinner i sent a photo to my
follower they approved they said it
looked accurate i felt like i can make
it again really easily and i definitely
will
hi hannah my name is tiffany and i would
love for you guys to try some chinese
style barbecue pork which is also known
as tasu and it is a really popular
candies dish you can usually make a
bunch of it and then serve it with rice
and veggies it's a really really good
dish and it's really delicious so i
really hope your family enjoys it i got
to buy a new wine to cook with for this
dish i had never tried it before
oh it's very salty it's definitely not
wine meant to be drunk but it is
delicious in food i made the marinade
that morning i got the pork in and let
it marinate for about eight hours okay
we're getting there we're burning a
little this looks pretty accurate i
served alongside some bok choy and rice
are you hungry
foodie time let's go this was probably
wyatt's favorite dish of the week he
wolf down that meat he loved it so much
i was
mind blown the marinade is stupendous
and there's all these umami flavors it's
so good oh
last thing to do was take a photo and
send it to my followers and they said it
looked great i'm so proud of that dish
completely worth the effort next up it
dawned on me that maybe it would be fun
to try a recipe that's native to my
heritage so i asked my mom for a
scandinavian recipe and she sent me my
grandma's recipe for kringla a lot of
the knowledge comes from just watching
someone make it and what's written down
in the recipe isn't really the whole
picture so i was really nervous to make
this one because it was on a recipe card
that my grandma wrote herself basically
just mix it like a pie crust so i got my
dough pressed out here
not quite as narrow as she does it but i
think it looks fine
here's what i did i did not order eggs
and i have no eggs
today's not my day
but luckily
we have chickens it started with four
and now we have 13.
i've lost it things are looking up for
me now everybody i'm a farmer y'all i
spread the cream puff type dough on top
of the pie crust popped in the oven to
bake when i pulled it out it was a
little lumpy
it was a little flat it was a little
pale but i figured it was close enough
and then i made an almond glaze yes it
looks somewhat accurate but i'm not sure
i'm waiting for my mom to answer tasty
the boys thought it was fine would you
like a bite
no
i sent my mom a picture and she didn't
answer
so
i packed up the kids and i drove to her
house to ask her to try it all right i'm
at my mother's house remaking kringla
because she criticized mine so much she
took one bite she chewed twice and she
spit it out and she said it was not
right i did not do a good job and i knew
she was right so i made it again but
this time i had regular large eggs and i
did the dough in two thinner strips
instead of one bigger strip looks
different i didn't realize you were a
connoisseur all right we are frosted i
had it covered overnight it looks way
better
wow
that is delicious henry ate it he
enjoyed my mom ate it and enjoyed and
said it tasted just like my grandma's
just goes to show that i still make
mistakes but i i fixed it
that's really good hello and i am rui
from indonesia you should try this
autoimm recipe because it's very rich
and tasty in indonesia so i am very
popular food and easily found on the
streets in a wet range of rice enjoyana
i'm so glad to share you this recipe bye
sotoyam is a chicken-based soup broth
with vermicelli clear rice noodles and a
lot of different toppings and some
amazing seasoning it required pecans in
the seasoning blend which i have never
thought of using i am sauteing my spice
blend so we're just going to let this
get fragrant it's really straightforward
actually you just simmer it for a very
long time and that's the bulk of the
effort is
waiting
and monitoring your pot it's about time
to take the chicken out of the pot and
fry it up so it's dry
i'm going to boil my noodles i just
sampled the broth
[Music]
holy moly it's good when the broth was
finished i removed the chicken and i
shredded it and then it was time to
assemble the soup
do you like it
that is
like the best
it's soup it's indonesian soup the boys
were really into it it's a really
kid-friendly dish what did you say
[Music]
it was so indescribably delicious it was
tangy
and rich in flavor but like nice and
salty but also really fresh tasting and
really light tasting it is one of the
best foods i've ever eaten in my life i
sent a photo to my follower they said it
looked good this is definitely something
we'll be making again it wasn't
difficult it's time consuming but you
don't have to do much during that time
so it's a perfect dish tonight we're
making jollof rice from nigeria i feel
like it's such an elevated rice because
usually my rice is a little sad so i'm
very grateful for this recipe jollof
rice is a
really really savory flavor packed rice
that has bell peppers tomatoes chili
peppers curry all of these seasonings so
the first thing i did was put the
peppers in the oven for a little bit to
get a little bit of smoky flavor and
then i blended those up with a tomato
then i sauteed some onions with the
tomato paste then i added my blended
sauce back in i added my seasoning then
i added the rice covered it with chicken
broth and i sealed the top of the pot to
make sure that the steam was trapped
inside all right we got some burned bits
here she said that was good it adds good
flavor
this is looking amazing
[Music]
jack's eats really quickly why eats
really slowly he likes the rice though
it's tasty it's impossible not to like
it's delicious i sent it to my follower
she said it looked good it was a true
relief to see that i did an okay job hi
hannah my name is sayo and i would love
if you and your family tried my recipe
for japanese tango um it is a super
simplified super easy version of what we
used to make back home in japan
and it's just something that like brings
back so many memories and i remember
making with my desk when i was younger
and i think it would be a really fun
activity for you and your family as well
i really hope that you enjoy and let me
know how it goes dango is a japanese
dumpling it's made with rice flour and
it's basically a blank slate it doesn't
have too much flavor to it because it's
meant to carry whatever sauce you want
with it so i have silken tofu and i'm
supposed to put in 200 grams of this
special sweet rice flour the problem is
they don't have a scale somebody
eyeballing this it looks like a mountain
of flowers
flour and butter so let's mush it up i'm
going to roll this into little balls
what else this is right i hope it is
let's do a test one and see how we do
okay so these are enormous so i'm going
to make some more
it's exactly what she said
it's like a blank canvas
maybe mine is a little too
loose like a little too watery so i kept
tweaking the ratios of tofu to rice
flour until i finally got it right kyle
and i were my friends after many many
rounds of tweaking the ratios i feel
like when i finally plated it it looked
accurate what do you think
y'all this was full
and i turned around and now it's empty
he is mowing this down and these are my
failed attempts and he still loves it
amazing
oh my gosh the boys went crazy for this
there was none left
what'd you say the best things i've ever
tasted they're the best thing you've
ever tasted yeah i'm almost fourth so
they still want meat oh yum so
make sure that's my
one another okay i sent a photo to my
follower and she said it looked exactly
how it's supposed to look which was so
nice to see if you're gonna make one
recipe from this week start with dango
it is so simple and you will have
learned a really amazing japanese recipe
i love doing this it has changed the way
that my kids perceive
different cultures and different foods
and just differences in general when i
tell my kids that we're making recipes
that you've submitted from all over the
world now they automatically approach it
with an open mind and so much respect
and they want to learn more about these
countries and it sparks such amazing
conversations and so much learning
that's the goal here so that's it for
now i'm hannah and tell me what you
thought did you like the dishes i made
have you made these dishes and what
should i try next time and if you'll
please excuse me i need to go make
another batch of pizzole immediately
until next time be sure to check out our
next episode i'm trying celebrity
parenting hacks for a week and some of
them are pretty weird you'll see
[Music]
you